اليوم يعود لاستعداد لاطلاق مهمه الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه بعد تاجيل الوقعه بسبب
مشكله في انظمه توجيه الارضيه يوم الاثنين
المهمه التي تضم رائد الفضاء الامارات
السلطان نادي اختصاص المهمه تعد اطول مهب
عربيه في الفضاوه تستمر لسته اشهر تضم
المهمه ايضا رائد الفضاء ستيفنبول قائد
عامه
اختصاصي مهمه روسيه
المشاهدين هذه الصور المباشره لاستعداد
لاطلاق مهمه مركبه الفضاء الاماراتيه التي
تستعد للانطلاق الى الفضاء في اطول رحله
فضاء عربيه الى الارض الى الفضاء لمده سته
اشهر
وطبعا نشير بانها كان من المفترض ان يتم
اطلاق هذه المهمه الى محطه فضاء الدوليه
يوم الاثنين ولكن بسبب انطلاق الان مباشره
نتابع معكم هذه الصور لي انطلاق الصاروخ
وهذه المهمه التي نتحدث عنها اول مهمه
طويله الامد لرواد الفضاء العرب الى
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه لاستمرار التقدم
الحضاري والانساني والمساهمات في مجال
استكشاف الفضاء والتكنولوجيا وحتى العلوم
المتقدمه لدينا كعرب وستخصص هذه المهمه
تحديدا لاجراء ابحاث علميه في الفضاء اذا
هذه الصور مباشره لانطلاق المرتبه
الفضائيه اخيرا الى الفضاء هي المهمه
الاطول عربيه تستمر هناك لمده سته اشهر
لاجراء ابحاث
وتابع معكم منطلاق الصاروخ الان مباشره في
هذه الصور التي ننقلها لكم عبر شاشه
العربيه وحيث من المقرر ان تجري هذه
المهمه اذا ما تحدثنا بالتفصيل عن عشرين
تجربه علميه بالتعاون مع كبرى الشركات
التي تعنى بالفضاء وبهذا العالم الذي ما
زال الكثير منه مجهولا بالنسبه لنا وما
زلنا في طور التعلم وطور التقدم لنعرف اين
نحن من هذا الفضاء العالمي حتى امام
المستقبل بان يكون هناك حياه في كواكب
اخرى فبالتالي المهمات تكثر المهمات تطول
ونحن كعرب اليوم موجودون اكثر فاكثر لكي
نسابق العالم حتى في هذا التكنولوجيا وفي
هذه المهام الى الفضاء
[موسيقى]